bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler d'une machine à inventer des
mots que j'ai fabriqué alors c'est pas
vraiment une machine c'est plutôt un
algorithme mais vous allez voir c'est
intéressant quand même l'idée m'est
venue en regardant la chaîne connue
c'est une chaîne youtube que vous
connaissez peut-être qu'ils parlent des
mots de la langue française et notamment
dans l'émission invente un mur à fall
qui est le créateur la chaîne met au
défi les spectateurs d'inventer des mots
sur un thème donné
j'ai enfin décidé de me lancer créer les
concours inventa nous comment ça va se
passer mais c'est simple il y aura un
concours toutes les deux semaines vous
m'écrivez les mots que vous voulez y a
aucune restriction
et du coup je me suis demandé quelle
était la meilleure manière d'inventer un
mot nouveau
vous allez voir que c'est pas si simple
que ça mais qu'heureusement les
mathématiques peuvent nous aider
imaginons que j'ai créé un objet nouveau
que je veux lui donner un nom bien à lui
c'est à dire un mot qui aujourd'hui
n'existent pas dans la langue française
il ya une solution qui est facile c'est
simplement de tirer des lettres au
hasard dans l'alphabet si par exemple je
fais ça avec julian neuf lettres au
hasard je peux créer un mot nouveau
comme ashba meubles excuse moi tu
interrompre en plein milieu de son
introduction
mais il est pas terrible je veux dire il
a un peu dur à prononcer h bawock qu'est
ce que c'est sûr je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais un mot comme ça bon déjà
c'est imprononçable et puis ça sonne
quand même pas très mots de la langue
française rien agents pour ça c'est que
pour qu'un mot et l'air de sonner un peu
français il ya quand même quelques
règles à respecter
déjà en français comme dans toutes les
langues il ya des lettres qui sont plus
fréquentes que d'autres donc un mot avec
2 w et un x c'est quand même assez
improbable ashba wake up
ensuite en français comme dans les
autres langues il ya des enchaînements
de lettres qui sont plus fréquents que
d'autres par exemple l'enchaînement bea
est relativement fréquent en français
l'enseignement à j ai probablement un
peu plus rares et puis il ya des
enchaînements qui en français n'existent
tout simplement pas par exemple on n'a
jamais un gie suivi d'un bep ou alors un
w suivi d'un x un autre truc pas très
réaliste c'est que momo là il se termine
par un cul et en français les mots il
termine jamais par inclus ben si la
coque c'est bien français le cac
ouais mais bon ça doit être le seul nom
et 5è tamasheq dont tamasheq seul
instant le dialogue dernière donc c'est
un peu moins connu que cinq écoles
mais quand elle enfin bref tout ça pour
dire que mon mot à jma machin si il a
pas l'air très français c'est tout
simplement parce qu'ils ne respectent
pas les règles d'enchaînements lettres
qui sont typiques de la langue française
donc si je veux créer des mots qu'ils
aient l'air un peu plus français il faut
que je trouve un moyen de respecter ces
règles
le meilleur moyen de connaître toutes
ces règles c'est tout simplement de
faire des statistiques sur les mots de
la langue française et donc bah c'est ce
que j'ai fait je me suis servi d'une
liste de trois cent mille mots français
qui a été compilé à partir des livres
numérisés dans le projet gutenberg et
j'ai écrit un petit programme qui va
analyser tous ces mots et faire des
statistiques sur les enchaînements de m
ces statistiques
elles nous permettent d'avoir une idée
de la probabilité qu'une lettre soit
suivie par une autre dans la langue
française prenons l'exemple de la lettre
f
vous voyez ici la liste des lettres qui
sont susceptibles de la suivre et avec
quelle probabilité donc par exemple la
lettre qui suit le plus fréquemment un
fc un pli avec 23 % de probabilité
ensuite c'est un deuxième f avec 14,5
probabilité un os avec 12% et c est
quelque chose de très important pour
chaque lettre il ya toujours une
probabilité qu'elle soit la dernière du
mot est donc dans le cas particulier du
f dans la langue française eh bien il ya
une probabilité de 1% qu'elle ne soit
lui par rien comme par exemple dans le
moche s et on peut faire ça pour toutes
les lettres alors les résultats de cette
analyse on peut les présenter
graphiquement sous la forme d'un tableau
de couleur qui va montrer la probabilité
de trouver une lettre après une autre
sur cette image ça va des casques bleus
qui représente les probabilités les plus
faibles jusqu'au 15 trous ce qui
représente les probabilités les plus
élevés proche de 100%
voici comme on lit ce tableau si on se
demande par exemple quels sont les
lettres qu'on peut trouver en français
après un peu et bien on regarde la ligne
du bo et on voit ici que la lettre r est
très probable la case et orange mais
qu'à l'opposé juste à côté dans la
colonne vu qu la case et bleu et donc ça
indique qu'en français c'est très peu
probable de trouver un cul juste après à
eux quand vous avez une case noire ça
signifie tout simplement que
l'enchaînement n'existe pas en français
ou en tout cas n'a jamais été
rencontrées une seule fois dans les
trois cent mille mots que j'ai analysé
on peut voir plein de choses
intéressantes sur ce tableau par exemple
vous savez qu'en français la lettre q
est absolument toujours suivi par 1 et
là on voit dans le tableau
la cage rouge ici elle représente le
fait que après un cul et ben on trouve
un u est à 99,9 pour cent de probabilité
alors c'est pas exactement 100 % parce
qu'il ya deux exceptions dans la langue
française la première voyez ici c'est le
cul suivi du y est c'est dans le mot
irakien qui est considéré comme une
forme correcte pour les habitants l'irak
et l'autre exception c'est un cube suivi
d'un ace et ça se produit une fois dans
la langue française c'est dans le mot
coq au pluriel
si vous regardez attentivement ce
tableau vous verrez qu'il ya quand même
pas mal de cases noires se dire qu'il ya
un certain nombre d'enseignements qui ne
se produise jamais dans la langue
française par exemple ici vous voyez que
le gie peut être suivie par les voyait
l'aï eu mais jamais par une consonne il
n'y a que des cases noires ah non ici il
ya une exception c'est le ji suivi deux
cas et c'est dans le mot pirojki
l'éclairage qui sont des sortes de
petits pâtés en croûte de la taille
d'une bouchée d'origine russe cuit ou
free que l'on peut servir en entrée ou
en accompagnement dans le tableau on
peut repérer d'autres enchaînement qu'on
l'air totalement absurde comme par
exemple un f suivi d'un elle est bien si
ça arrive dans le mot hafnium qui est le
72e éléments de la classification
périodique ou bien des suivis d'un cas
qui se produit une seule fois dans votre
cas ça pour éponger les pirojki ou bien
un double à ça ça arrive dans le mot
afrikaans et y en a encore tout plein
d'autres dans le domaine impôts
scientifique on peut citer
l'enchaînement x suivi de m
eh ben ça se produit dans lux m et flux
m way et on peut trouver d'autres mots
comme rick stan rien à voir avec une
rixe lindahl il s'agit simplement modèle
utilisé pendant plus de 200 heures dans
le commerce néerlandais à partir du
xvième siècle comme hôtes néo pro
choisir gymkhana avec un cac suivie d'un
h
ce mot vient de lindy gymkhana il
désigne simplement un lieu dont les
équipements permettent la pratique de
nombreux sports et de nombreux jeux
s'agit menace quoi un gymnase casino
gymkhana jim casino on peut aussi
utiliser ce tableau pour chercher d
exception aux règles bien connu la
langue française par exemple vous avez
dû apprendre que 1n se transforme en m
quand il est placé avant mb ou p et bien
pas toujours si on regarde attentivement
le tableau on voit que c'est pas des
cases noires les enchaînements nml bnp
existe bel et bien et les mots qui
correspondent ces bonbons main bar
néanmoins cyr convainc de mainmise main
morte pour bon point et pearl un papa
tout ça c'est très amusant mais je vous
rappelle qu'on n'était pas là pour ça
puisque le but de la manoeuvre c'est de
créer des mots nouveaux
alors maintenant qu'on a ce tableau de
probabilités de transition entre les
lettres de la langue française
comment on va l'utiliser pour créer des
mots nouveaux qui sonne français eh bien
il se trouve que en probabilités il
existe un concept qu'on appelle les
chaînes de markov et qui permet
justement de créer des suites qui
respecte des probabilités de transition
il y aura plein de choses à dire sur les
chaînes de markov mais essentiellement
nous on va l'utiliser de la manière la
plus simple qui soit c'est à dire pour
créer des suites de lettres dont les
probabilités de transition suivent ce
qu'on avait dans le tableau quand on a
une lettre on regarde les lettres qu'ils
peuvent la suivre
on regarde les probabilités associés et
on tire au hasard la lettre suivante en
respectant ses probabilités et ainsi de
suite
on recommence pour créer un mot est donc
le premier mot que j'ai créée en tirant
au hasard selon ce procédé
et bien c'est le mot angely alors il
existe pas dans le dictionnaire j'ai
vérifié mais vous voyez qui sonne quand
même beaucoup mieux que h m évidemment
tout ça est assez facile à programmer et
donc j'ai écrit un petit code qui prend
le tableau des probabilités et qui en
une fraction de seconde fabrique des
milliers de mots qu'ils respectent les
règles de transition de la langue
française est donc là vous voyez un
exemple de ce qu a créé le programme
pour des mots de huit lettres c'est pas
mal non
alors sur ces mots il faut bien
comprendre que j'ai fais absolument
aucune sélection et aucun tri 1 c'est
les motels qui sortent du programme j'ai
pas du tout choisi les meilleurs et vous
voyez que ça sonne quand même beaucoup
beaucoup plus français que simplement de
tirer des lettres au hasard je peux vous
donner d'autres exemples cette fois avec
des mots de six lettres avec des mots de
dix lettres
et puis pour le fun on peut même créer
des mots de douze lettres
j'aime bien le gaz aux idées qui seront
évidemment de temps en temps on retombe
sur des mots qui existe vraiment par
exemple si vous vous amusez à faire ça
et à chercher des mots de quatre lettres
vous allez voir que le mot con ou
plurielle revient assez souvent je sais
pas pourquoi
pour bien se rendre compte que cette
méthode est le produit des mots dont les
enchaînements de lettres sont vraiment
spécifique de la langue française
on peut s'amuser à refaire tout ça en
utilisant au départ des mots allemands
c'est ce que j'ai fait voyez ici le
tableau de probabilités d'enchaînements
de lettres en allemand et vous pouvez le
comparer aux français et voici les mots
que notre machine fabrique si au départ
on lui a donné des maux allemand je suis
pas très fort en allemand mais je trouve
que ça sonne assez jerman dont ce qui
peut devenir vraiment drôle c'est
d'utiliser les mots qui ont été inventés
par la machine pour créer des textes
bizarres vous savez un peu façon oulipo
je me souviens quand j'étais au lycée
notre prof de français s'amusait à nous
infliger les poèmes de saint john perse
tu sais pas si vous connaissez cette
hauteur mais dans ses poèmes qui a
toujours tout un tas de mots
incompréhensibles
en fait c'est des mots qu'appartiennent
vraiment à la langue française mais qui
doit être le seul à utiliser genre ça
je n'ai veille sont jointes aux fruits
noirs de la nive danse à cupules virus
et donc aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de me
venger de saint john perse en écrivant
moi même mon poème incompréhensible donc
ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai gardé
les petits maux les plus courants la
langue française et puis au milieu j'ai
casé tout un tas de mots qui ont été
produits par la machine à jour montrer
ce que ça donne après avoir faut lui
donner toute la nuit nous rue mam
enfin auprès du conte briques et là
tandis que les friands de des oilers à
l'émeute
nous accordons noko giri qui n'avait
cessé de flée sait depuis des heures
quelques offices verrai ça et là mais
sans pour autant à connecter les démons
11 et soudain une horde de parts d alice
car foule à vernoux armée de stival rice
de flammes mais les montées sur des
autres qu'on leur sueur vers nous des
soutifs là heureusement nous avions nos
mornac tout en il en parle à pékin nous
décidâmes de palliser avant que le train
pour nice
les parts d alice avait beau démographe
et loriot petits vont ils durent se
résoudre à chamars dire une fois de plus
notre intra bhl champs paris nous avait
permis de te re et les l'aigre-doux
départ d alice pendant des anges riz et
des anges riz lait cil khoury pourrez re
rios neno et après merci d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu
je voudrais particulièrement remercier
raphaël de co2 mu qui m'a inspiré
soutenu et encouragé donc n'oubliez pas
d'aller vous abonner à sa chaîne
s'ils voulaient comprendre un peu mieux
comment j'ai fait pour créer tous ses
maux et bien j'ai écrit un billet dont
je vais mettre le lien et qui détaille
un petit peu coup précisément comment je
me suis créé pour faire les statistiques
et plus pour faire la chaîne marks or si
les mots que j'ai inventé comme ça vous
inspire n'hésitez pas à me proposer vos
propres textes épiques qui les utilisent
et puis vous pouvez aussi proposer des
définitions pour certains - on en verra
les meilleurs à raphaël comme d'habitude
vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook twitter vous pouvez
vous abonner à la chaîne vous pouvez me
soutenir sur tipi pour ceux qui
souhaitent merci beaucoup à tous les
types heures merci infiniment
et puis vous pouvez me retrouver sur mon
blog sur cette annonce merci à
bientôt
en fait saint john perse c'est vachement
bien je vous le recommande